foreign
ladies and gentlemen and Welcome to our
planning committee meeting today we have
three applications to consider a report
on that this and intend to take the
business in the order they are set out
on our agenda
item on apologies for absence
yes chair we've received a couple
apologies from councilor William
Armitage substitute substituted by
councilor cleancliff councilor Al
Hartson substituted by councilor T Lacey
councilor Jay Ridgeway and councilor P
Elliott thank you chair
are there any further apologies
um two Declarations of Interest
members are requests
interests already on their interests in
India
offering at the appropriate time do any
member of any interest to declare
counselor Hancock
hi Chad I don't really know whether it's
about willing to Pace of transparency I
have made representations on two of
those appeals so just on item end thank
you
no one else
thank you
1923 for them that is
any against
any abstentions
thank you the Motions being carried
moving on to the main business before we
start I will ask the clock to explain
for the benefit of members speakers and
those watching on YouTube how we will
deal with them
thank you chair this is the procedure
for considering for considering the
business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to adjust the meeting
speakers will have three minutes to put
forward their views
will be a remark given by the clerk when
30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
after the speakers addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting but they will not be allowed
to participate further from this point
the chair will then open the meeting up
for questions to officers a debate by
the committee and finally determination
on the application by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
family members this meeting is being
live streamed and a recording will be
made which will be placed on the
council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you moving on to the main part of
the agenda which is item four which is
the first application Ned forward slash
400391 forward slash FL at kelstage
Alice are you ready for presentation
thank you
can I please remind members that there's
plenty of time for questions after the
presentation thank you
thank you chair
this application is for the cladding
Public House a Timberline 2 shelter
extension alterations to porch two
Timber pergola seating structures
structured for a four Court sign trellis
fencing on top of a stone wall to West
boundary extensions to the rear of the
public house and the rear of smoothie
Barn a detached hobby workshop and rear
1.8 meter height close board Advanced to
the northern boundary of Cal State Inn
Matlock Road carlstage
this application was submitted in May
last year following a period following a
period of time seeking an application
for the works that had begun that
doesn't sound good
um however accurate drawings showing all
the works proposed were only submitted
at the beginning of January an extension
of time was originally agreed until
March 2023 however on reviewing the
proposal and the recommendation for
refusal the planning manager made a
decision to bring the application to
this committee this is because this
allows time for members to consider the
application and if members are minded to
refuse the application today officers
will then have sufficient time to begin
enforcement proceedings
the site is located within the center of
calstage and is colored orange on the
attached plan the site is within the
settlement development limits of Cal
State but is it is also within the
primary area of multiple environmental
sensitivity and is therefore within the
district's most special and protected
landscape
the site is prominent and clearly
visible from Matlock Road as a
consequent the site sets the tone for
the rest of Cal State and is a building
against which other development will be
judged
next slide please
this is the red line plan for the
proposal the application site includes
the calstagin and smoothie barn and the
next one is
this is the proposed block plan showing
the timber structures to the front of
the property and the proposed extensions
to the rear
existing and proposed front elevations
show the extension support and the
cladding on the areas to the building
closest to Matlock Road
horizontal gray composite padding has
been installed on the western North
elevations of the building
this means
the cladding extends to the
um part of the rear elevation single
story extensions are proposed which will
create a large kitchen and new reception
room area within the public house two
rooftop Terraces will also serve as
amenity space for Smithy Barn next one
please
um this is existing and proposed Eastern
elevation
and excuse
it's considered that the extension to
the extensions to the rear are
acceptable as they are below ground and
well screened they will not have a
harmful impact on the carriage of the
street scene or the immunity of
neighbors although it should be noted
that by providing capacity for more
covers the increase in the potential
volume of business may have an impact on
parking in the area
one piece
this photo taken from the north shows
that the extensions are well screened
due to the landfall and Boundary
treatments
these
a number of Timber structures have been
constructed to the side and front of the
building they include the swing which is
shown here
the applicant states that outdoor
seating was required during a covid-19
pandemic at that time the government
provided permitted development rights
for outside structures for this purpose
however this PD right was removed in
January 2022 suggesting that the
government did not intend such
structures to be permanent their
retention therefore needs to be
regularized by planning permission
other Timber structures include a
seating structure
and
the pitched Reef side structure has also
been constructed
and then the last one is
a number of different boundary features
have also been constructed
notwithstanding whether the cladding is
acceptable the applicant has agreed to
paint close by defense to the rear ends
of the site in a greater match that
cutting next slide please
this Google Street View image from April
2019 shows the coastage in before the
changes for which applicant seeks
permission were carried out as you can
see the building was relatively simple
with outside seating to the front of the
property and unimpeded car park spaces
the portrait was not particularly
attractive but was relatively unassuming
Smithy Barn is the building in the
foreground on to the right of the
picture
please
this photo shows front of the building
now
and the next one please
and you can see that Timber structures
have taken over parking spaces reducing
the space in the car park
and next one
this again shows parking spaces being
impeded the last of parking space is an
increase in parking requirements
resulting from extra internal and
external space has a harmful impact on
the immunity of neighbors by extending
parking onto the highway
next slide please
the porch has increased inside in size
and is no longer unassuming but
dominates the front of the property
vertical Timber is in contrast to the
light gray horizontal Compass composite
cladding on the side of the building
exactly horizontal gray composite
cladding is not in keeping with the
local Stone vernacular the light color
and synthetic appearance makes the
cladding stand out and the darker gray
Verge edging for the urban size assists
the quad finish further detracts from
its appearance in The Wider Street Scene
the synthetic composite material is
unlikely to weather
next slide please
these are some of the photos which was
shown at yesterday's site visit
some more and then the next one
and then local and National planning
policy in places great weight on the
importance of good design sustainable
development officers of the view that
whilst the rear extensions are
acceptable the cladding porch and Timber
structures are not the problem here is
not necessarily individual items but the
cumulative impact are different
differing materials colors and
instruction which creates a cluttered
appearance to this site this is harmful
because the building sets the tone for
The Wider character of curl Stitch due
to its Central prominent location and
importance to functioning of the village
no evidence has been put forward showing
that the loss of the Timber structures
would result in the business being
unviable as such it is considered that
there are no mitigating circumstances
against the harm caused by the
development as consequence of the book
it is recommended that the proposal be
refused
thank you chair
thank you
I believe we have three speakers for
this item does anyone want clarification
before we move to the speakers
council poster
only for clarification at this point
questions will be at the end yeah
so first speak this afternoon on this
application is the ward member councilor
William Armitage William are you there
yeah can you hear me yes off you go
three minutes
okay thank you very much
uh Cal Sage is a growing Community with
the 14 new houses which have been built
and uh or some of them are in the
construction stage and and these are
being built in the last 12 months the uh
Pub is a necessary amenity not only
supplies much sort after employment
which is very important to people but it
also supplies a good selection of food
at a reasonable price much of this
popularity was brought about by the
refurbishment by the owner of the
outside
this was a result of the cladding which
gave it a clean modern look the outdoor
pagodas gave people the option of eating
Outdoors or indoors very popular to the
many Walkers who get off the bus and go
in for their breakfast and then they go
for a walk come back uh have their food
and get back on the bus there are all
over 40 miles of Fort path in the ashova
parish the amenity Value Plus the
employment Factor far outweighs any
other reasons for refusal the clergic
looks quite good it's toned down by a
lot more than when it was first put up
first will decide well there's a side
High Arrow uh uh at the farm shop which
is bigger so yeah that's that uh
well uh the king actually visited our
show but in 2005. it was actually Prince
Charles said and he presented it uh the
village with the village of the Year
award
and he spoke and he said that the pub is
the heart of the community on this Pub
certainly does that and I can't help see
all these reasons for uh turning it down
when it's doing a very good job in the
community and I cannot see any reason
for turning it down when you consider
the cladding ultimately and look at the
cladding that we put on the council
houses uh and so you can see that and
all the gentlemen has done is make it a
good clean uh Pub uh well the outward
appearances and as a result it's brought
people into the
pubs remain
has made the pub more viable and that's
it uh I won't say anymore other than the
fact that I think I should have been
my ash over ones should have been heard
when I was available but there you go
foreign
Foster
thank you chair
um uh good afternoon William
good afternoon uh my question is have
you received any complaints yourself
about this uh I know it's not to do
another question is not about what uh
Williams uh me speaking about but he is
the local councilor and if you'll allow
a chair I think it's relevant uh have
you received any complaints yourself uh
about this its appearance because it's
all to be up
um any comments from any negative
comments from residents none whatsoever
in actual fact people have said uh what
a transformation it's taken
thank you councilor Armitage our next
speaker is Simon oxbrane
if you'd like to take the chair
you just need to press the red button
you'll have three minutes when you're
ready
good afternoon I'm Simon I've owned the
Cal station for 23 years we've had eight
tenants previously and four years ago we
took back control
which recently spent 70 000 pounds on
refurbishments
Cal State is a small village however
it's got a huge heart
our Pub is the only Community facility
our Facebook page has over 2 000
followers and we host christenings wakes
weddings birthdays wi meetings walking
groups dog fairs Mother's Day Market Etc
local customers drink regularly with us
they travel by foot bike taxi and get
dropped off the core of our community
and making everyone welcome
we employ 16 people seven of which are
full-time and our young staff learn
important skills
food is a huge part of our business
without it we wouldn't exist
we use good local suppliers
during co-ed of course we had to close
but determined not to give up on our
business we spent the time making
improvements
customers were not allowed back inside
and we had social distancing and from
the government's advice we created out
extra outside seating
it's been very difficult to keep the
business going
we are starting to get back to normal
but it's a new normal people's habits
have changed they come out earlier they
eat earlier they don't stay out late and
quite often we're closed by 9 30.
the developments enhanced our customers
offering
some like it busy others like it quieter
atmosphere it's not about increasing
capacity it's about creating different
more spread out areas
the outside space is very important to
our customers and we think we've made it
a welcoming and safe place
without these changes I just don't think
the business is sustainable long term
the pub was not Stone on the rear and
side it was rendered
the render was very poor condition I've
repainted it three times
it quickly looks scruffy again because
of the road I felt it necessary to use a
more sustainable finish so we chose a
good quality recital product
which is surely better than bubbling
render
I've not cluttered any stone work
I think the cladding looks smart and our
customers agree
I've had I've fully cooperated with the
council by employing professionals
submitting an application
making it clear that I am Keen to
discuss the project
I took advice and removed several of the
items I'd put in front of the pub to
make it look less cluttered
we are very pleased to have received
many more letters of support for our
application and concerns
the three concerns that have been uh
received are from the same household
we've only lost one car parking space
due to the outside seating and we
encourage our customers to park that
sometimes yeah
thank you thank you are there any
questions for the speaker do you remain
where you are just a second counselor
can I ask you how many car parking space
as you have
um we have seven
okay so and you got rid of one just one
space you're saying yes
right and how do uh you feel if people
parking outside is that on the lane that
there would park if it wasn't room
within the park on the causeway and they
also Park on Ashoka Road or roll into us
over thank you
any further questions
yeah thank you good afternoon good
afternoon my question is
obviously uh we spoke just about the
parking spaces can you tell me how many
disabled spaces you have
without one just one yes so there's no
room to put another one
well we could make in one of the others
uh but there isn't extra space to make
another one I'm just wondering because
obviously more and more people now have
got a mobility issue
and of course this and I know exactly
where you are I've visited you many
times and I'm just wondering about the
mobility side you know regarding if
you've got more than one person
I I would if I could answer I would I
would say generally that car park space
isn't used and it's not used on a you
know every daily open basis and people
other people do respect the fact that
it's in a disabled space and if I find
somebody that's parked in it that I know
the vehicle I've asked them to move oh
because it's you know it's unfair to
make sure that we can give accessibility
when we first did the improvements to
the pub many years ago we formed a ramp
which people can walk around people walk
around are in wheelchairs or get pushed
in wheelchairs or have
um
the frames yes yeah thank you
just to confirm I heard right you've
lost one space yes
counselor Jones
yeah I'm just a bit because you know the
bands that we can see that wooden fans
going along
um I think that is a bit of an eye so
on the whole I've driven past many times
and I think it looks good you know the
what the like or and the sign and I've
even said at the time you know oh that
looks good now you know you can notice
it really well is there any way that you
could put some plants in front of that
stuff just put soften it up and make it
more sorry are you talking about the
fence at the rear of them yeah yeah well
the the one elevation which goes on to
the
um
the flax are really it'd be difficult
for me to do anything there because it's
not my land
that comes down to a green that goes
onto the main road
um yes we could put some planters on
there but that would then be coming onto
the pathway so I don't know how that
would be viewed
up a bit oh yeah well we've also we have
also agreed that you know if if it needs
to be painted
um we would tone it down with painting
to the same color as the we can get a
round number for the paint color for the
cladding and we'll paint that you know
and I've already agreed to do that I
haven't done it because obviously I'm
waiting to see what the outcome of this
is thank you
I do have a question for you and I'm a
bit concerned all this work has gone on
without any form of planning permission
right
did you actually have a lot of input
from the planning officers or did you
start the work without permission well
obviously they've started the work
without permission I did but if I'm if
I'm totally and I am on being honest as
well I seriously didn't realize that to
put the cladding on or the fencing or
change the front of the put in the roof
on the porch that I would really need
planning permission so I was ignorant at
that and I was I was wrong
yes we did start work in the back of the
building uh on the site and we have done
a fair amount of work the moment the
council came and asked the told to see
me about it I've stopped work and I
haven't done anything since then so I
have or yes I was wrong I didn't get
planning permission to start with but I
have complied with the request of the
council uh not to do any further work
thank you for your honesty thank you any
further questions
no if you'd like to take your seat thank
you
and the last speaker
Charlotte Stanton
Charlotte you know the drill
thank you
Simon has apologized for starting the
work before checking with the council he
thought he was doing the right thing
preparing for reopening after the long
and difficult curvy closure
government had issued advice to create
outside areas
the committee report confirms that the
rear extensions are acceptable the
concerns raised by the officers relate
to the cladding porch fencing and Timber
structures
however I have an email here from the
original case officer dated the 6th of
June 22 which confirms that the cladding
porch and science structure were all
acceptable
all subsequent negotiations with the
council were carried out on this basis
and we were even told to match various
elements of the cladding like the paint
on the fence
last week when the committee report was
published this was the first time we had
any idea that these elements were no
longer agreed
this is completely unreasonable to Simon
the council had agreed an extension of
time until the end of March to enable
negotiations
an email from Emily it is stated that
the removal of the cladding would
actually be harmful to the appearance at
7.14 you are advised that the cladding
is not in keeping with the stone
vernacular but these elevations of the
pub were not Stone they were bubbling
painted render
your officer report advises you at 7.5
at the principle of development in in
the village is acceptable
you are required to make a judgment
about the design and to balance any
issues with the benefits to the
community facility
the report raises various issues about
color or finish or screening of elements
which could soon play have been
discussed with us the painting of the
fence for example will be completed if
permission is granted
we welcome that there are no objections
from any of the statutory Consultants
including environmental health comments
have been made about loss of parking but
only one parking space has been lost
there are no parking standards in the
local plan and this is a local facility
where many people walk the highway
Authority is not objected
the officer has confirmed that the issue
about parking impacting on neighbor
immunity was based on objections from
one household we understand that
occasionally people may Park
irresponsibly and this could cause
inconvenience for a short time but is
this really a major immunity issue that
means planning permission should be
refused I'm not aware of the street
parking amenity issue for one house ever
being a reason for refusal before
if Simon put movable tables and chairs
or other structures in the car park this
would not require planning permission
the structures have been fixed for
Safety and Security
you've heard from Simon what an
important Community facility this is we
all know many pubs that have been lost
we ask you please to play significant
weight on the importance of supporting
this local pub in making your decision
thank you
thank you can I just have some
clarification shot and I could have
asked Simon I'm sorry I just looked at
this picture leading into the porch
there's two steps is there another
disabled access point there is yes thank
you yes at the sign
thank you are there any questions
councilor foston thank you chairman
thank you for that uh that letter that
you held up give me a permission could
you expand on that a little please it's
okay to quote it but can you read out a
little about what he says I've heard
that letter okay chair thank you sure
it's Emily Cartwright was the case
officer before she left the council
um this is an email from the 6th of June
22 giving feedback on the planning
application that I'd submitted the month
before
um what she's done is she's provided a
series of headings as she goes through
each of the elements of the scheme so
for example extension to the rear of a
public house and then a paragraph on on
each
so extensions for the public house the
two extensions are deemed to be
acceptable I'm summarizing
what's only female
extension to Smoothie Barnum Workshop
the proposed extensions are deemed to be
acceptable
porch alterations the timber awning
support new picture of gray Timber
cladding alterations are considered to
be acceptable
cladding to Public House
whilst the composite gray finish
cladding is not necessarily considered
to complement the design of the
development
we have taken a balanced view now sorry
on a balanced view it has been taken
that is it is acceptable because to
remove the cladding would be more
detrimental to the appearance of the
public house
science structure the existing signs
surrounding Timber and slate roof
structure is considered to be acceptable
Timberland 2 shelter extension Timber
pergola and the swing structure
the concerns were raised about these
elements and we were asked to look at
the citing form massing and Design
we'd reduce the Clutter and we looked at
the materials and offered to make any
amendments that they wished us to make
in that respect they they said that at
the present time these were not
considered to be acceptable so that was
in June
the 1.8 meter ship black lap fencing to
the north and east boundaries are
considered to be acceptable please
consider a collar similar to the
cladding so we did that
the trellis fencing along the west
boundary is not considered to be
acceptable
they asked for more information on
levels which we provided and they
confirmed we're acceptable they asked us
about the solar panels which are
confirmed with permitted development and
they asked us for more information about
the parking and the highway Authority
raised no objection
so at this point in June 22
everything was acceptable apart from the
lean to
Timber extension which has since been
clad to match the pub on the left hand
side of the pub
and the timber pergola and the swing
everything else was confirmed as okay so
as far as we were concerned we were just
working on those elements
any other questions comments thank you
Charlotte thank you
all right we're going to come to the
interesting part questions to the
officers
any questions councilor Foster
my question is when we look at the uh
the recommendation at the end and how
it's worded and what we've heard from
from the officer
um
the reason why it's been refused so we
can see uh the first two parks and the
third part is around the loss of parking
so it's a major part of the reason why
the recommendation is to refuse so we've
got the loss of parking spaces and
increasing parking requirements
resulting in uh in extra internal and
extra an external space as a harmful
impact on the immunity of neighbors and
it says here has a harmful impact
um so I'd like to question how this has
been put across when the office
described it uh that the lady said may
have an uh harmful impact for me it's a
small point but we've got to be careful
about things like this when it's
something so important as supporting a
business so does it have an awful impact
in the officer's view this this loss of
space or it may have a harmful uh impact
and it's important to me because a lot
of this hinges around for me this this
parking space uh so perhaps an
explanation on that it may have a
harmful impact or does it good
I can start sharing and Alice can add
something if that'd help the the
fundamental issue for members as with
all these things is it's a matter for
your judgment and you will need to take
a view on whether the impact on the
parking and you've heard from both the
applicant and officers our views on that
you'll need to take a view whether the
displacement of that parking whether it
be one space two spaces three spaces
whatever you judge is the appropriate
level and from your understanding of
what you've heard whether that has a
knock-on impact then on asking being
displaced onto the highway and the
country impact on Humanity of the
neighbors and the Judgment that we have
come to as officers is that that level
of displacement does have that harmful
impact but I think that the number of it
for me um as has the Foster started
share was it's an amalgam of all these
various issues and you've heard again
this afternoon
um a Miss Dayton quoted you an email but
um we put together back in June but it's
it's an amalgam of all those elements
rather than one individual element that
goes together to lead to our conclusions
on the acceptability of the scheme so
hopefully that helps on the part in the
issue anybody but ultimately be matter
for yourselves as a planning committee
to sake of you on that point
uh if we may come back Chad I appreciate
the uh the explanation and thank you for
that Adrian I think I was concerned more
that I was introduced that it was it may
have an awful impact it was that it was
that statement because it's I know it's
not written down but what's written down
is it will you know and it may and
there's a difference to me
um just yes it's our judgment that it
would but but he was planning committing
on me to take a take a view on that the
applications that I'll obviously as she
would
councilor Hancock
thank you chair it's kind of the obvious
question really is why is there such a
disparity between what was said six
months well eight months ago and uh
what's being said today
the I think the the issue as just
discussed with is an amalgam of those
elements and
um the officer back in June took a view
on that I've had to review the whole
application before bringing it to you
this afternoon and it's the retention of
all those various elements that together
in in the opinion of officers leads us
to our conclusion
irrespective of what was said in June
and what said now it's still the
decision that you have to take so you as
a planning committee will need to take
the view on whether the cladding is
acceptable whether the ancillary
structures in the car parking is
acceptable so fundamentally you've heard
what's been said
you will still need to take a judgment
on that irrespective of what we said in
June what's putting our officer report
now so the the issue before you Remains
the Same
um I think what I'm kind of getting at
there's obviously
um I mean typically when it comes to
looking at planning applications and
refusing planning applications we should
be doing it on technical reasons and
objectively this is obviously saying
there's a lot of subjectivity here
because we've had two officers have very
different opinions on identical
situations
um and I think that's my concern
we're we're getting what was clearly
um Emily's opinion when she was here the
opinion now is different but nothing's
actually changed things have actually
been taken away which you can address
that so as there seems to be a little
bit too much subjectivity here rather
than the object of the two normally have
um with respect yeah I I disagree with
that the fundamental issue for members
this afternoon Remains the Same
irrespect of what officers said because
we bring to you a recommendation and
sometimes you you record with that and
sometimes you don't you need to bring
your own judgment to the application
irrespective of what was said in June
what what's said now so I know what
councilor Hancock says about the the
office of you changing over time but
fundamentally the issue Still Remains
for you as planning committee to sake of
you on the application and I'm sure
you'll do that based on the information
that you have and you'll you'll need to
assess the application based on your
planning policies in respect to the
design of
um new development which is
fundamentally the the issue for officers
here is the is the cladding and the
refurbishment of the purpose
whole acceptable bearing in mind that it
includes both alterations to the
building and the structures that are
placed within the car parking area so
that that fundamentally Still Remains
the Same
any other comments questions
I'd just like to say something
I find it extremely difficult Satay and
looking at what's in front of me and
then hearing that in actual fact it was
okay
[Music]
sorry
I find it extremely difficult that you
know sort of so many months back it sort
of was looked as though it was okay
but
um now it isn't
this are indeed an awful lot of money
that I obviously
been spent
and I find it a quite a difficult
situation to weigh up one way or the
other
for one I don't like adding but at the
same time I realize that there's
uh the gentleman probably went along
with what he thought was would be
acceptable I find that extremely hard
but can we just clear up the um
applicants and the agents are saying
there was one parking space has lost
and in the recommendations of a fuel it
says the lock of parking spaces plural
the um parking I made a Judgment of what
were parking spaces in the um looking at
historic
um aerial photographs
um
I think looking at it I think there were
probably eight and we would argue there
are now six but I do recognize that
there appear to be cars parked
underneath the um
one of the uh Timber pergolas so I guess
to make a judgment as to whether that's
still a parking space or not still a
parking space if it is then it's loss of
one space for the participant then it's
a loss of two I would say
if that makes sense
uh thanks chair it's a similar similar
name really I'm looking at the picture
on
um page 17 of the car under the pergola
under there
and which uses that pergola to the pub
that's that's my first point
I don't know if I've ever used this car
park and it's probably a question to the
the either the Aging tour the or the
applicant but
it looks very tight in there and they
look like obviously there's a swing
there's I can see a bench is that
how difficult in in the opposite opinion
is it to maneuver in that car park to
both to get in and to get out safely and
also to ensure Public Safety within that
car park
yeah and the car park isn't isn't huge
but I think there's adequate space to
get in and out
and yeah I don't think I think that's
probably all right I've used the car
park and it's not massive but you can
maneuver safely
but that was before the swing Etc was
put in there my concern would be
children running about in there
and not being supervised yes
yeah I mean I have to say
um taking a taking a balanced view on
this the thing for me is definitely
about
what's actually in the car park at this
moment
not the view of the building I've driven
past it many times
and yeah it may not be to everybody's
liking but it but it's without a shadow
of a doubt it's it's certainly smart and
and it looks like it's
um he looks like it's a problem it's
like a part of a community and it's
obviously well used
the thing that really concerns me is is
what's going off in that car park
yes I don't think I don't know if you
can see the um
the cursor but the swing there's the um
there's a sign and then the swing and
then the Pagoda which has got the car
parked underneath it at the minute
and then there's more Timber structures
over where the seating used to be before
because we go to the previous picture
though you can see there was always
seating outside
but it was just
um benches on that piece of gravel area
oh
Council Foster thank you chair
um but I understand the questions about
what's going on in the car park I
understand why members are asking about
them which you just said concernable
what's going on in the car park but when
we read the summary in conclusion this
is not something which has been involved
in uh the reasons for recommending uh
refusal we can we can see through them
all all at the bottom of page 22 through
to the what's on page 23.
um the the the recommendations for
refusal were were different to that
they're based on the policies ss7 SDC
E3 oh it doesn't mention what's going on
in the car park so I think we have to be
careful as a committee you know when we
come to making a decision that we are
considering the right policies rather
than just saying what's going on in the
car part that is you know that shouldn't
be affecting our uh our decision with
respect yeah
and I take your point that my concern is
safety of anyone using that car park
regarding of what planning policy is and
I think that's something we should all
be concerned about
Council line cook thanks chair um it's a
question for officers
um in terms of of what options are
available to us because I think from
what I'm hearing I think other people
have kind of got the same thing going
through their head as I have I think in
principle a lot of us don't have an
issue with what's being done but we do
have concerns with those car park the
pergola and what's around it so what
kind of if if and when we when we come
to making motions what kind of options
are in front of us if we want to reject
officers recommendations but kind of
keep that area as something that needs
further discussion
yeah
we did give this some thought to chair
about and potential
um what we would call the split decision
and you could take a split decision on
the application if there was one element
of it that was clearly distinguishable
from the larger part so it couldn't be
the larger bit that you didn't like and
you were proving a little bit if you're
in something you would need to have
objection to a smaller bit so and
hopefully this helps and Castle Hancock
but in this instance you may
and and at least so correctly if I'm
wrong legally on this I'm sure but you
could take a decision to approve the
vast majority of what's proposed so the
cladding the porch the other extensions
that haven't been completed to the rear
of the building the defense Etc subject
to condition but by condition
specifically exclude retrospect
information for
structures within the car park for
example or certain
parts of the car park if you if you
could split that off and it does stand
to my mind to the distinguishable from
much of the rest of the the schemes that
was an area that the planning committee
were particularly concerned about and
didn't find acceptable for whatever
reason and and there's been discussion
about
the movements within the car park and
the use of those facilities that's
that's the first assessment that wasn't
the conclusion we came to his offices
bearing in mind the comments from the
highway Authority on the highway safety
element if you like but you could if you
chose
differentiate say the the pergola and
the swing from everything else to retain
those car parking spaces and
in effect refuse them by limiting
condition
the other alternative you have of course
is to to refuse the applications or to
approve it as a whole boat so you've got
those I think you've got those three
options in US sounds right
Council again
I know what council Foster was saying
about the car park shouldn't shouldn't
really be an issue but I was just
thinking there are three pubs in Ash
over literally half a mile down the road
uh one of which doesn't have any car
park and the other one has a much more
dangerous car part than this one
that's just my opinion but there you go
and I think in a village called the
lucky to have a car park at all
councilor Hall
thank you yeah what the operations
please what are they uh comments 9.2 for
refusal is the cladding so whilst it
looks nice it does remind me of
something you'd see more at the seaside
than in Russia over but one of the
things
um
that would concern Maize it's big it's
there already and it except so we'll
when you say about dividing it into
different uh points or sections say
uh if we were Martin I'd say to refuse
that the issue then would be to get it
removed but would
would there be a better option or what
what would you rather be in a way I
don't know stone or what there was there
before I'm not sure for all to the
option is
if we're remanded to vote
but out to keep it or if we get it
removed then
um is there a photo of what there was
before I don't know things
it was
um the side and rear elevations that
have now been clad were rendered painted
render
Ed there are photos
um on
um Google Google Street View
okay just to come back please so so just
to like some of it like that photo shows
some
Stone isn't it yeah so
all just to clarify it's not correct
yeah the front elevation was Stone
beside and I think
art or all of the rare um I'd have to
check that uh was rendered
okay thank you
if there are no more questions for
officers I'll open the floor for debate
oh Council
um yeah I was just going to say about
architectural Merit from padding versus
render uh I know what the pub used to
look like and it looked dirty I'll be
perfectly honest with you and I I don't
really think there's any architectural
Merit in Gray render
you know but also Cal State is a it's
not a picture postcard Village I'm not
going to offend you I hope
um it's a very very mixed Village it has
all sorts of architecture ages
Etc including I think the 14 new houses
that William mentioned I hope I'm
referring to the same ones a little new
development on the right hand side
heading back into Usher over the last
houses in kelstage in my opinion how
they were ever passed is beyond me
because in my opinion they are very very
1960s in style very flat roofs big
garages at the front Etc
um so personally I don't think
you can't really
have a go about the cladding because
obviously that side of the pool must
have been severely damaged to get it
rendered in the first place I know
people have had render removed and the
sewn the stone is usually in such a
diabolical condition underneath you
can't sort of remove it and hope to get
stone back so I can understand why
they've done that I did think it was a
little odd until I saw what was there
before
so thank you
okay the floor is still open for debate
councilor Foster thank you chair
um what I'd like to speak about is is
supporting businesses we often speak
about it as a council and as if
individual counselors but when you look
at what support businesses actually do
want they want the uh they want to be
allowed to do business and they're the
experts when it comes to making money
employing people and paying taxes and
keeping our country running
um we've got an idea as counselors and
some counselors are business owners but
we should be leaving that we should be
supporting businesses they've been
through a very difficult time A lot of
people are forgetting that Kobe it's
only for business owners only a short
time away where they're only just
getting back on the feet here we've got
a business owner that's invested heavily
in the community and being honest with
us I accept what's being said about
starting the work
uh without
um but without the permission but I can
see the sort of work that was done uh
someone not uh that upon
um uh planning permission Matt well have
started now I'll take the gentleman's
word on that and then he's worked with
us he's had from that letter that's
being led out he's been uh he's been led
to believe that what he's doing is
acceptable so you can see he's worked
with the council
so
for me I like the idea of uh of being
able to support uh businesses and I
think that's what we should be doing uh
that's just on the business side of
things on the other side of things one
we've not spoke about and I've only just
touched on it when you look at the
reasons for uh refusing uh which is ss7
stc3 and stc-12 and we're talking about
um at the car park I think we've got to
be careful when it comes to if we do
refuse this and we do put things in
about I haven't been considered and
given advice from officers before so we
answered that advice if we put things in
here about that car park there's no
reason to say well that can't be it
taken to appeal and it can't be dealt
with differently because we can't just
invent things and invent our own
constances we might have got concerns
about car Parks but without policy to
back it up that's not going to stand up
appeal it's not going to be a sound
judgment which will stand up at an
appeal I'd be more than happy to hear
from officers on on their view I know
it's a debate art but I'm more than
happy three officer's view on that for
me if it's not in there already we don't
back it up by policy it can be quite
easily taken to appeal so we've got to
make uh sound decisions we've got to
make a defense defensive decisions when
it comes to it so just two points I
wanted to make one is the
about supporting businesses and the
other one is about being careful making
judgments and how it stands up at appeal
thank you chair
councilor Hancock
thanks chair I think I mean one of the
key things here I Won't Say I'm a
frequent visitor there because I'm
certainly not but they have actually
improved this public enormously it looks
a lot better than it did previously and
I think that's that's one of the key
considerations we've got totally get
where Mark's coming from on that last
last comment I think I think one of the
key bits here and it is a key criticism
and I think Alice actually touched on it
when she was doing her initial
presentation
the guidance from the government over
the covid stuff and the permitted
development rights there was woolly and
I think
um the the gist that we have from the
email that Charlotte read out
um everything was working fine but they
wanted further discussion on that bit
about the uh about the um pergola and
the swings Etc
personally I would be more comfortable
if those discussions were still kept
open because I do think they do need a
bit more discussion but yeah that we
haven't got anything substantive
to grasp hold of and it it is on dodgy
ground and it potentially could become a
test case because of that lack of
guidance from the government which is a
fault of theirs
um but yeah I mean the key thing is they
have invested as a business but they've
made it a lot better and that's top and
bottom of it so I think it would be
stupid to turn it down if I'm honest
any other comment
no I'll go to the motion stages anyone
want to put counselor Foster
thank you chair I'd like to make one
that we give uh planning permission for
this as it stands uh based on these
reasons and are based some on the uh the
recommendations uh in the middle of page
23 quoting policies ss7
sdc3 and SDC 12 all of the local plan
ss7 that is appropriate in scale
designer location to the character and
function of the settlement
stc3 but it does not con cause
significant harm to the character
quality distinctiveness or sensitivity
of the landscape both of those were
discussed uh all of us when it came to
the planning what it looks like and
stc-12 uh that it does respond
positively to the local character and
context to preserve the local identity
so I'm happy to propose that as it
stands and uh quote those three policies
thank you chair let's learn cool thanks
chair I second Council and fosters
proposal that we reject officers
recommendations on that thank you
we'll go to the vote Yes I do briefly
chair
um just come in before and you take the
vote just in terms of the motion I
understand the motion just wondered if
members are
concerned about any particular issue
whether you want any matter controlled
by condition and I particularly know the
the comments of the highway Authority on
page 11 and also those are the
environmental health officers from page
11 regarding travel plan and the hours
of work during any subsequent
development and there is further work I
understand that would need to be taking
place on the site and just ask members
if they've got any conditions in mind or
whether
you're content and that's the only issue
of clarity just asking for the votes
taken share through the chair can ask
what the recommendation would be from
officers
my view would be you would it would be
appropriate to put a condition on
restricting the times when the work
could take place on any subsequent
building works because it is in close
proximity to
um flats and other Residential
Properties in this instance in view of
the
proximity of um bus route or a bus room
bus routes I think and I personally
don't think a travel plan would would be
something you would need to place on any
approval to make the development tax
actual I think that's perfectly adequate
opportunities for people to travel here
you talked about people traveling to
walk using public transport Etc so I
don't think you would need that um in
terms of other other conditions I can't
think of any in view of the works having
started and those that impacting under
the front of the property I don't think
I would recommend any other conditions
and because the work's already started
so that's that's my recommendation would
be you would normally want to control
the the title and the words could take
place to those that wouldn't affect the
near Neighbors
and what would be the recommended to the
chair what were the recommended uh times
the environmental health office is
recommended between eight and six Monday
to Friday and on Saturday mornings from
nine till thirteen about one o'clock in
the afternoon we would normally um or to
condition restricting it to eight
o'clock on a Saturday morning to to one
o'clock
yeah I can go wrong with that councilor
Hall
yeah sorry just before we go to the vote
on page 18
7.18 you you have uh stated about the uh
bending single painted Timber fencing
introducers another mixture to the
material on site adding to the
impression of clutter so is that a
condition you would like uh adding or
anything what would you like uh to be
seen seeing that really
I was going to say Roger I believe the
applicant has already agreed that he
would paint the fence so it's toned down
to match him with the rest of the
cladding
does that need to be added as a
condition though no it's already agreed
to it if members of minded to approve
the the application we would normally
put on an approved plans condition and
shown on there so it would it would be
part and parcel of that and unless
members wanted to to leave the the fence
and the color into
for the owner Master Foster move to the
vulture
AJ I think we're clear on the uh
um motion uh councilor and cliff
councilor Cooper
councilor Foster
or
counselor Hall
for
counselor Hancock for
counselor Lacey
for
councilor League oh
councilor Jones well
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse or
and councilor ruff
uh unanimous chair the motion has passed
thank you
we'll move on to the second application
for this afternoon and that is Ned
forward slash two two four zero one one
six four four FL at ashova
when you're ready Alice
redhead catch up with Owen
hang on
stuck
that's me
oh
okay
thank you chair
uh this application is for the
conversion and extension of an existing
bond from a single residential dwelling
and direction of a new Storage Barn it's
a revised scheme of twenty one zero zero
seven one three FL at Alice said Farm
Alice Head Road ashover
and the application
um so yeah sorry the application is a
resubmission of this game submitted in
2021 which which allowed the conversion
but with a smaller extension
the site is located to the north Alice
Head Road and is outlined here in Orange
the barn is part of Alice head Farmstead
and forms the North Eastern side of the
farmyard the site is located within the
primary area of multiple environmental
sensitivity and therefore in the
district's most special and protected
landscape
this is the block which shows the barn
proposed for the conversion and the
location of the new storage building in
the Eastern corner of the proposed
Garden it is considered that as a
consequence of the need for this storage
building the conversion would result in
a replacement of an agricultural
building which is against the
requirements of Criterion F of policy
sdc-1
slide please
the application is for the conversion of
a building including the conversion of
an extension to the of a modern
extension to the rear of the property
however this modern extension has been
demolished so that so the proposal has
been considered as a conversion of the
traditional barn with the extension to
the rear as a new development
this photo shows that the modern rear
extension has been demolished next Slide
the applicant has a permission to
convert the building which includes a
small extension these are the approved
drawings
you can see it's quite small
um these the plans and elevation
drawings for the storage building
although it is proposed to be
constructed of Timber boarding on a
stone plinth the proposed storage
building appears industrial being
completely enclosed with one full height
door in this area truly agricultural
buildings tend to be open at least on
one side providing ventilation and
access to livestock Etc
that's a livestock building
back to the barn conversion is
considered that the traditional element
of the building is a permanent and
substantial construction and therefore
capable of conversion it is considered
that this element of The Proposal is
acceptable and indeed the applicants
have a permission to convert the
building with the small extension
approved to the rear however clearly the
previous existing large utilitarian Rare
Element is not capable of conversion and
is as it no longer exists
as such a rare element has to be
considered as a new extension to the
traditional Barn
the proposed extension will represent a
60 increase in the size of the building
and as such it is considered to be a
major extension which fails to meet the
requirements of Criterion B of policy
stc-1
next slide
we're building an extension are clearly
visible from the footpath to the rear of
the property
sorry
and here is another view from Little
path
extension would be visible with some
vegetation screening from Alice Head
Road the storage building proposed to
the Garden area would be clearly visible
and it is considered would not be
informed by it or sympathetic to the
valued landscape as it is industrial
rather than Agriculture and Style and
what we read as a modern building
separate from the existing built form
and the last one and the proposal fails
to meet the requirements of conversion
policy due to the scale of extension
proposed and the need for a new storage
building as it is clearly visible from
public viewpoints and no details of
materials for the extension have been
submitted officers are of the view that
there are no material considerations to
outweigh the harm of the to the
landscape which is therefore recommended
that the application be refused
thank you Alice thank you
I believe we have one speaker for this
application counselor Alma teach are you
there William
yeah if I can start the video
it's been the host has disabled it so
can you put it on that one
we can hear you
I know that Roger
the horses asked to use the camera if
there's a line on it
there we are right off we go three
minutes when you're ready
thank you
uh right uh there's an obvious need uh
for this Barn uh and the rep the remains
of the Cow Shed to be converted into a
home at the moment there is a family of
five living in a caravan and as far as I
can concerned this is not acceptable uh
because there is a bond on site which
would make a house for them
7.4 uh on your documents points out that
local and neighborhood plans support
uh the principle of conversion of a bond
to a dwelling
policy SDC one supports this and it was
approved uh item it was 21 uh uh Slash
zero zero seven one three so FL
the proposed extension replaces an old
disused cow they took it down
because it was falling down it wasn't a
modern building at all and it uh there
is a great concrete slab to prove the
point uh that it was there
you've now said that uh it there
shouldn't be allowed because it's uh an
incursion into the countryside as a new
build well it wasn't it was staying down
because it wasn't safe and it wasn't a
modern building in any case because cows
were never housed in cowshed uh well it
was up until after the war
we then go to the uh argument about the
building uh down the yard there
uh the officer has stated that it's not
an agricultural building it's not an
agricultural building which is used for
livestock we accept that but with the
amount of theft that's going on on farms
and roundabout we have to have Secure
Storage and that's what the building is
designed for Secure Storage
and it is needed and I look at it like
this this plant should be allowed it's
not necessarily uh
into the the actual
uh Countryside uh and then kill
incursion because it was only seconds
remain
so there you are there is a need and the
family is living in a caravan and it's
disgusting
counselor
are there any questions for councilor
elegant just for clarification William
because I honestly don't know the answer
to this one are they actually farming
the land or did they just buy the house
and Surround I think they're to do with
the farm quite frankly
I know the the lady is right okay
any other questions
no thank you William
thank you
are there any questions for the officers
councilor Rouse
thank you all I need to ask you know to
say that they actually live in on the
land in the Caravan must have been any
permission given for that Caravan to be
on site
I don't believe so no
my question for officers is around 8.2
submarine and conclusion it's about the
the unsafe what was called an unsafe uh
is it the lean-to which was demolished
and it can no longer be considered as a
as a conversion I must be assessed as a
new extension I gather though that the
the base is still there is that correct
so just some clarity on that please
uh yes the base is there but the rest of
the building isn't there and therefore
is is not not a building that you know
well can't be converted because it
doesn't exist
um the policy is very clear that
the buildings have to be capable of
conversion to meet the conversion policy
or or if they're to be extended it
mustn't be a major extensions
so on that chair just just because
you've said that that our local policies
are very clear uh just we're about so
while while this meeting is going on can
I just look it up uh that policy which
policy it is
it's policy SDC one
of the local plan is that the stc-1f
that you spoke about
uh
it's it's on page one two three of the
local plan yeah
um a to G of the various strands of it
and as officers we've gone through the
the various strands in our report and
the elements that we are
there were two elements to the barn
there's the Stone Barn that you've seen
on the photographs which we accept
um is our permanence substantial
construction we accept that that could
be converted however the and you've
heard cancer say that the other part of
the building that was there fell down so
that that's now gone so from the point
of view of
um your policy is that element of
ability should have been capable of
conversion to achieve the the policy
stance and character says it was in a
poor State and fell down so in in an
office of view we would concur with that
that part of the building wasn't capable
of conversion and so we're taking the
policy on its face that the version of
the building should be capable of taking
place for that major alteration
adaptational reconstruction and our view
is that because that part of the
building was in a poor state it doesn't
meet that Criterion of the policy
so we we've disaggregated the two we
accept that the the Stone Barn has Merit
and could be converted indeed we've
granted permission as you heard Ali say
for its conversion with a much smaller
extension previously but argue is that
the size of the extension now proposed
to in effect cover that footprint to the
previous building is two significant in
size and therefore doesn't meet the
Criterion of policy SDC one and that's
on the basis of our recommendation team
okay
let's look at you know just just a
question is that correct then an
agricultural Barn when it's got a roller
shutter door on becomes an industrial
building
Alice will correct if I'm wrong here but
in this instance it's being constructed
as part and part of this application to
provide for storage don't believe with
any evidence or information that needs
to be used specifically for agriculture
if it was for agriculture then it would
be applied for as an agricultural
building but but again in the discussion
I've just had with councilor Foster
strand F of your policy SDC one talks
about the new use resulting in
replacement farm buildings or
inappropriate outside storage
Etc and that that adds weight to your
office of you that the proposal by the
removal of that element of the building
that fell down but also by the
conversion of the building which could
be used for storage Europe that uses
will lead to the creation of this other
building within the garden of the new
dwelling that would be provided so that
adds weight to our conclusion in terms
of the overall merits of the the
conversion extension
any other points to officers counselor
Hall yeah thank you we've heard about
councilor Armitage uh talking about uh
five people living in a caravan but I
guess that's uh on on the side of the
Caravan on the site but I guess that's
not something relevant to the actual
planning application is it
and that you've heard me say this to
planning committee many times but you
need to take your decisions in
accordance with your development plan
first and foremost unless other matters
outweigh that conclusion so the
discussion that Council Foss and I have
just had is relates to policy SDC one
part of your development plan you need
to weigh that up with the other relevant
elements of the development plan if you
think there are any and then making
inclusion on that point does it Accord
with your development plan or not
bear bearing in mind that conclusion
other than any other matters so weighty
that outweigh like that um initial
consideration and our viewers officers
is that the policies of the your
development plan are so
clear in this this circumstance that any
other matters don't outweigh that and
there are clearly other options open to
the family in any case because as as
we've heard we have granted permission
for the conversion of the building but
with a much smaller extension than that
now proposed and there are other
Alternatives as well and and we've not
in any way sought to
um lead to this conclusion this
situation where they're in a caravan but
there are I believe at least one other
family living within the farmhouse on
the site so there is other residential
occupations that are there as well so
the view of offices is that there aren't
any other matters that outweigh that
initial consideration on the merits of
your development plan hopefully that
answers the question I hope so
any other points to the officers
nope in which case I'll open the floor
for debate
councilor Hall thank you I think to make
sure that we don't set a precedent or
anything and from what we've heard from
the officers I I propose that we go with
officers recommendation
you can't do the motion just Roger
Council angel
I'm sorry apologist
yeah I think this this is one of those
awful situations where your heart says
one thing and and your brain says
another
um it is I mean I I think if they
actually separated the two applications
and we were looking at the the domestic
bit and then the storage I think it
might be a little bit easier but but it
does it goes against policy SDC one if
we if we were to approve him I don't see
any way around that so
um whilst whilst my heart goes out to
them and says yes they need a nice house
they have got that fullback position
and I can't see that proving this will
be consistent with where we stand
any other comment
no counselor Hall would you like to put
your motion forward yeah please I like
I'd like to uh
propose that we could go with officers
recommendation to refuse the application
please thank you I will second it
Adventure
um motion is to approve office of
recommendations
uh councilor ancliffe
councilor Cooper
councilor Foster
councilor hall for
counselor Hancock for
counselor Lacey for
councilor Liggett oh
councilor Jones four
councilor Powell
councilor Rouse
and councilor off
motion has been approved here
thank you
okay
and the final application for today is
Ned forward slash 22 forward slash zero
zero three nine one forward slash FL
brackenfield
it's your last one Alice deep breath
just just waiting for the computer to
capture
sorry we'll just take a minute oh there
we go yeah
thanks chair
um
this application is for the conversion
of the barn to a dwelling at more Grange
doho Lane Bratton doll yeah go whole
Lane brackenfield
this is a revised scheme of
2200-504 which was refused last year on
design Brands and because the app can
also propose a number of new
agricultural buildings
it was considered that because of this
proposal did not meet versions policy
the application site is located to the
north of dohole Lane it is um a barn or
former equestrian building to the
northeast of the dwelling known as Mor
Grange
side please
this is the red line location plan you
can see the applicant has included the
surrounding land in Blue Line
this block plan shows that the barn and
proposed Garden area to the north sorry
this block plan shows barn and the
proposed Garden area to the north
parking will be to the front
this is existing and proposed South and
West elevations you can see that with
the exception of new roof lights
existing openings will be used
these are the existing and proposed
north and east elevations two new
openings are proposed on the rear North
elevation along with two new roof lights
it is considered that the designers in
keeping with its surroundings and the
character the building and its setting
next slide please
this is a photograph of the existing
South elevation is considered that the
building is of permanent and substantial
construction and is capable of
conversion
um it's therefore considered that by
virtue of this design and
by virtue of this and the design The
Proposal meets the conversion policy
this shows the East and North elevations
and this is the North or rear elevation
the site is visible from the Open Access
land to the north but as you can see the
building itself is well streamed by
mature trees
the building is also visible from the
footpath to the east
these are photos of the building from
Fields closer to the site and it's the
top one on the right
um and that's just another photograph
of the building
and finally
from Dewey Lane to the South the
building is obscured by trees
it's considered that as a consequence of
this design and the fact that
um it's not very easily visible from
publicly accessible viewpoints the
conversion meets requirements for the
conversion policy SDC one and therefore
it is recommended for approval
thank you chair
thank you
we have our speaker Council Armitage
when you're ready William
yeah uh I didn't realize I was speaking
on this but I will see them here uh
I don't have any uh qualms with this at
all
um I think the office has made the right
decision on it
that's all I wish to say
thank you we're all going to sit down in
shock
very much
are there any questions for councilor
Armitage
counselor Hall
sorry too yeah page 39 1.1 the
application has been called into
committee by Council of Armitage reason
impact on the landscape and mass ends up
any concerns then you mean
notes
[Music]
thank you
any other questions for Council on the
teacher
okay any questions for officers then
no
I'll open the floor for debate or we can
move straight to motions I can see
everybody looking
[Music]
no debate oh
councilor there's no debate I'll move
reckon the uh we follow the officer's
recommendation thank you um
thank you have a vote on that now please
councilor ancliffe
councilor Cooper
councilor Foster
councilor hall or
counselor Hancock or
councilor Lacy for
counselor
councilor Jones
oh
councilor Powell
counselor Rouse
and councilor ruff
that's unanimous share the motion has
passed thank you
moving on to item 8 planning appeals and
lodged and determined
members will see each other there's only
the one appeal that's reported this
month and that's the enforcement appeal
at page 53 you may recall
um our colleague Julian coming to speech
about various matters
um previously and this appeal is one of
those that
um was
um raised at that and that discussion
and just to commend Julian on the work
that he put into this and the outcome
which is a very good decision for the
council in terms of unauthorized Works
within the green belt and it was a
public inquiry
he put I say put an awful lot of time
and effort into the appeal with
colleagues grateful to him for that and
it is a very good decision for the
council and I do mend it to to members
to give that a good read when it came
through and if you didn't and if you can
spend 15 minutes having a look at it I
think it does raise a number of issues
but not least the
important argument development in the
green belt week it goes through in quite
good detail well argued and well thought
through so just commend that to to
members chair thank you
thank you if you'd like to pass on my
thanks to Julian to the Sterling job on
that thank you
well I have no urgent business so good
afternoon to you all thank you for your
time